And to show you this relationship, I will do the following--for each of the edges that is blue
over here I will draw in here and I will color them black and I'm going to do the same thing
over here, so each edge that is blue over here I'm going to draw in black over here.
Now, and I hope you can see it here even with my drawing that is not very similar,
it turns out that this graph over here
once I've added all the edges from this graph is the same as this graph here
once I've added all the edges from that graph over here
and this is exactly the connection between clique and independent set.
If you have solved clique on a given graph,
you take another graph where you draw exactly the opposite edges.
Every pair of vertices that is connected by an edge in this network
is not connected over here and vice versa
but this means that finding the largest possible clique in one graph
is basically the same as finding the largest possible independent set in the--
well you can call it an inversed graph where you connected exactly those vertices
that where not connected over here
and it's the same the other way around.
If you have found an independent set in a graph that is as large as possible,
then the same vertices will form a clique if you build the inverse graph.
You connect all of the vertices that were not connected over here.
This is actually a great news for Bob and for Carol
because if Bob were to find a polynomial time algorithm for clique.
If he were to determine that clique is tractable, then independent set would also be tractable
because Carol could just take her network,
build the inverse network, then have Bob solve clique on that network,
take that same solution for her problem.
Carol wanted to take independent set which she would basically do as
she would start out with a graph
then she would build the inverse graph and solve clique.
That would give her the same solution as if she were looking for
an independent set on the original graph.
And it's the same for Bob here because if Carol finds a good algorithm for independent set,
what he can do is he can take his graph, also build the inverse graph,
and then solve independent set which means that either both clique and independent set are tractable
or both of these problems are intractable
but it cannot be the case that only one of them is tractable or intractable.